(singing)
(chattering)
- Sorry, I had added—
- And a Sprite?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Uh huh, uh huh.
(electronic music)
♫ Oh the sorrow
♫ I'm down in the world
♫ All alone
♫ And I have
♫ No home for tomorrow
♫ I'm trying to make this city
♫ My home
♫ Oh Lord, sometimes I'm gonna talk ♫
- What, what up?
Trying to see what?
What are you trying to see?
We're just doing a documentary.
A documentary!
I'm Claressa's little sister!
The boxer!
No I'm her little sister, fool!
Yeah!
Thank you!
Good lookin', fam!
- Welcome back everybody,
thank you so much!
My guest tonight—
- I am the best female boxer in the world.
- Grew up in Flint, Michigan.
- [Claressa] I have this dream.
- In the world.
- Little bit of pressure.
- [Voiceover] For Claressa—
She could be the first—
Two Olympic gold medals—
- Oh, I love ‘em.
- [Voiceover] Claressa.
- Claressa.
- [Voiceover] Shields.
- [Voiceover] Claressa Shields.
- [Voiceover] Claressa Shields!
- Claressa, truly an inspiration.
- [Briana] A lot of
people don't even know me.
Like a lot of people just be like
"that's Claressa's sister."
I have no problem with
that, but don't be like
"oh that's Claressa's
sister, she need to go do
what her sister doing."
No I don't.
Everybody always trying
to compare me to Claressa.
But this is my life.
(gentle music)
- [Briana] But at the
same time, a lot of stuff
that I think is okay,
it's really not okay.
A lot of us in Flint
are stuck inside of our
own world because we're
so used to struggling.
I got used to my
momma throwing me out
at three o'clock in the morning.
I'm used to failing, and buying food stamps
just to make ends meet.
I'm used to not having to listen to nobody
because I was always kinda
doing alright by myself.
When Claressa left me,
I really took that shit
hard bro, I ain’t had nobody.
But Claressa had to leave
to really succeed in life.
I feel like Claressa
meant to be on TV and I'm
meant to be in the streets.
What if Claressa would
have stayed with me?
What if Claressa ran the streets with me?
We would both be fucked up out here
with nothing.
(giggling)
(babbling)
- [Briana] I never wanted my
son's name to be Bradford.
He's been Fat Daddy since the womb.
Before we even found out
if he was a boy or not
he was Fat Daddy.
Even if he was a, came out a
girl, he was still gonna be
Fat Daddy.
(giggling)
(playing)
- Fat Daddy!
I'm a full time Fat Daddy mama.
That's what I am, that's my life now.
Fat Daddy come put your shoes on, come on!
Fat Daddy I've been thinking of you!
Are you thinking of me?
(bright music)
- He is so handsome with his haircut!
His hair grow back
fast, so I might be back
in two weeks!
Say "We out here!"
(babbling)
- Come here, look at me!
Ooh, handsome!
(laughing)
You fat as hell.
(babbling)
- I wanted to get pregnant.
(silly noises)
- I wanted to have a baby because I felt
abandoned by everybody.
Everybody chose when they want to care
and love me or whatever.
So I said, if I have my own baby,
all he gonna want is me.
All he gonna need is me.
And all he gonna love is me, and he gonna
keep on loving me till the day he die.
He ain't gonna never stop,
I wanted my own baby.
(babbling)
- Whatever, we going to the zoo!
(squealing)
- We going to the mother fuckin' zoo!
(babbling)
(electronic music)
- [Briana] Claressa is really
living her life already.
She got her shit together, now I gotta get
my shit together.
(electronic music)
- [Briana] If I actually
wanna do something
with my life, I'm capable of doing that.
I can't let my situation define who I am.
I can't let that make me.
I'm a statistic.
But that's not all I
am, I'm more than that.
(electronic music)